you
[Music]
hi welcome my name is Kelly O'Brien I
work at our studio as a solutions
engineer and my talk today is on showing
you some configuration management tools
if you happen to be an analytic
administrator or as we kind of like to
use the term in our admin so I'm really
happy that our admin as a concept as a
role is becoming more recognized in
different organizations and people are
starting to identify as this personality
in different organizations but in case
you don't know and our admin is usually
as as we define it a data scientist who
has crawled into doing more ITX
type work so they take on the jobs of
onboarding new tools deploying solutions
and supporting existing standards and
their organizations they work closely
with their IT groups to maintain upgrade
and scale their analytic environments
they influence others they train they
try to make things more effective in
their organizations and in general
overall they are really passionate about
making our a legitimate analytics
standard in their enterprise so if
you're not familiar with the art admin
you think you might be one you want to
read more about it our director of
solutions engineering Nathan Stevens put
out this blog awhile ago on our our
views blog called analytics
administration for our so definitely
check that out if you are interested in
reading more as part of this you know
overarching set of goals that we have
for our admins a big part of doing the
work of an are admin is is making our
legitimate in your organization so the
our admin looks at their enterprise
analytic infrastructure on a wider scale
than maybe a traditional data scientist
would they are aware of all of the
different integration points and all of
the places where be assisting in helping
manage that that infrastructure so we
kind of think about these things in
three different parts your first step is
to get or recognized as legitimate if
you are in the back room and he's giving
you the secret server and you installed
are on it and you're kind of doing
things in a shady way and giving people
access to different things like we
understand that that's going on but
we're trying to give you a framework to
move out of the shadows and bring our
into the light so in order to do that we
say it's important for you the our admin
do you develop competencies in using our
professional stack so in order to do
that you need to get hands-on experience
with understanding and managing this our
tooling and finally you need to the step
to communicate with our your IT
department and get our adopted and
finally hopefully help others in your
organization so that they all get to the
point where various teams are all
relying on integrated are based
solutions so that's the ideal but we
understand that this is kind of a an
open-ended framework and it can be kind
of frustrating and difficult to navigate
because we don't have a lot of
actionable steps listed here
one of my friends Adam recently and the
past couple of months started this
thread on Twitter that was really really
interesting where he reached out to the
arts community and said hey does it have
resources for starting conversations
with ITU I'm struggling to make are an
accepted part of our software kit and
and I know Adam and he is a very
talented capable our admin but he's
feeling stuck and so a lot of people had
some really interesting ideas for him
you can go and check those out but our
standard advice as a place to start is
that number one think about how if at
all you can get yourself a sandbox what
is a sandbox the sandbox is is any kind
of server or VM that you the our admin
has control over completely control and
you can practice giving yourself those
copy
disease so we have this resource
available on our github which is the
soul and github and this one is called
the data science lab and it very
basically takes you through assuming it
assumes you have a clean ec2 AWS
instance to work with but that's not a
hard requirement these commands will
work on other servers as well and it
takes you through all the parts of
installing and configuring a very basic
pro stack so those include systems
dependencies and building are for source
and installing packages and installing
our studio products and all of the
various integrations that we consider
basic ones that are nice to have once
you've done that manually we would then
suggest that you might be ready to
explore the fire hose which is my
favorite place dockstar studio calm and
on dark sorcery comm we have all of the
quick links to get to all of our admin
documentation so if you're interested in
focusing on one or many of these
products this is the place to go our
admin Doc's are wonderful and they're
full of many different side quests to
explore in your sandboxes so I highly
recommend this site for getting started
with the art of the possible so I hope
at this point I've sort of explained why
I'm excited about sandboxes why I think
other people should be excited about
sandboxes unfortunately even though we
give this advice like quite a lot we
don't see a lot of people actually
taking us up on it actually building
their own sandboxes and showing us what
they've done and getting hands-on
experience so for my talk today I wanted
to think about like what kind of talk
could I give that would have people
leaving this room being like yeah like
super excited about them
so that's I've done instead of talking
about the basic sandbox
which I've sort of already done I want
to talk about Oh sandboxes and this is
kind of how I develop sandboxes my daily
work as a solution engineer I've the the
privilege to be embedded on the our
studio konnekt team and help them out
with testing new features and figuring
out how things work so that we can
deliver the correct documentation to our
users so I do a lot of creating
quicksand boxes that live for a very
short periods of time but I'd like to
save all of my work so I like to create
the ability to have reproducible you
know custom environments that I can go
back to and visit through my github if I
ever needed them again and the way I do
that is through configuration management
tools in particular I mean this is a
bunch of the top players in that space
but they're very many and it's easy to
get overwhelmed by the sheer number of
tools available but my favorite of the
configuration management tools is
ansible take this with a grain of salt
because I'm going to spend the next
several minutes talking a bunch about
ansible but I do not believe that you
should use ansible if ansible speaks to
you more power to you I think that's
wonderful
I think it's a wonderful tool go out and
learn about it but I would suggest first
checking with your IT team to see if
they use a configuration management tool
and instead of investing your time in
learning the one that I like when the
one that they use especially if you
intend on staying in your organization
for any period of the next several
months because that is going to really
grease the wheels for helping you
communicate with your IT if you speak
the same language as they do if you can
show that you know how to administer the
are stack using the set of tools that
they're comfortable with that is a
hugely powerful thing so some things I
like about ansible are of course that I
can
stand up these servers right quickly in
custom ways on demand
but I also really love the rich module
ecosystem that it comes with especially
the modules that they have around you
know your basic big players in cloud
compute space so you have great modules
for for AWS seizure GCP and they have a
lot of other modules some of which I'll
talk about today that that are also nice
to have and helpful
the other great thing about ansible is
that you write play books and yeah Mille
and that's awesome because it is super
human readable and super machine
readable and I love that it's also super
easy to install this is how you would
install it on a Mac and then you're up
and running so I'm gonna go through kind
of what creating an ansible project
looks like but as a high-level overview
before I move on to the next slide I'll
say that what I'm going to talk about is
kind of a nested directory of Gammell so
the very container ish level you have
thanks for beeping you have your your
playbooks and then within play books
you're gonna have roles and then within
roles you're gonna have tasks so I'm
gonna go through all of that first with
the playbook role structure so this is a
project that I actually did a couple
weeks ago to help check out the new
feature that just got announced a couple
minutes ago in our studio konnekt 1.7
which is support for these new content
management api's that allow for
programmatic deployment of content to
connect and so this is what my playbook
role structure looks like and I'm
showing right here the create sandbox
playbook and this playbook contains two
roles one for provisioning my cloud
infrastructure and a second one for
installing our studio konnekt on it so I
have this playbook create me a Samba
and then within that playbook different
things happen and I connect to it in
different ways but I have two rules one
provision one install and configure this
again is is about the content management
API is for programmatic deployment it's
kind of a two for one in this talk
because I was very excited about this
feature that's coming into connect and
so if you are working with your IT
department and and you've ever heard
these two questions hey we can't allow
push-button publishing or you know how
do we implement a dev test prod setup I
believe that that our new stuff around
programmatic deployment will be really
helpful in having those types of
conversations there is the key resources
the our studio user guide has just been
updated with a cookbook for various
server API recipes and we also have a
github repo that has scripts that have
you know examples of how to do
programmatic deployments so those the
scripts that are in this github repo are
going to be really useful and those are
the ones that I used in this ansible
project so again back to roles as I
mentioned before these roles have tasks
and the basic anatomy of a task is that
you know it's a good idea to name it and
that name should in general be relevant
to what the task is doing and then you
also provide the module that you want to
use finally if if it's applicable you'll
then provide parameters for that module
and plug in your variables there are a
couple of really cool things that are
happening in this particular group of
tasks and this is the entire role that
this ansible project uses to create and
upload and deploy the content so this is
programmatic deployment
as defined in an ansible task listing
the cool things that are happening here
is that I am leveraging the script
module because if you thought like this
can't possibly be all that prophetic
deployment is that's correct I'm I'm
leveraging some shell scripts because I
didn't want to take the time to transfer
all of the commands in those scripts
into ansible code so the scripts that
are provided in that github repo I
grabbed those out I put them in a
scripts directory I added them slightly
to make them do what I wanted them to do
and then I'm just calling those scripts
and you can it's a really cool way to to
take baby steps into moving any of the
configuration scripts that you currently
have into a more reproducible
configuration management type workflow
so that's the number one cool thing I'm
doing number two is that you can see
after I've run that first task I'm
registering an output object of what
came out of that first script and I'm
plugging it in to the second and the
third task the final cool thing is is
that I remembered to use a debug
statement which is also great
I'll start moving faster okay so I
talked about rolls have test this is the
test for the deploy content role and and
finally when you're ready to get up and
running with your playbooks this is kind
of how you run play books one by one so
I talked about I usually have two or
maybe three play books that I'll run to
in any given ansible project sometimes
more but usually two or three and one
will be the the playbook that installs
and sets up my infrastructure installs
whatever I need on it and the last one
will be the playbook that tears
everything down this is my favorite part
of ansible Sam
boxing once you have created this thing
you now have the power to write a good
read me check it all into version
control and then burn it all to the
ground because you have the ability to
reproduce this environment at anytime
within minutes which is awesome and so
that's a little bit about how I do daily
work as a solutions engineer who works
with engineering teams and how I stand
up these environments very quickly
whenever I want
but obviously you would do things
differently you have different needs for
sandboxes and so this slide kind of
shows what is available at a high level
through doc solder studio comm and all
of the various configurations and
integrations that you could possibly use
this this is a little resource that I
have available on our so lounge github
and it covers if you aren't ready for
the cloud yet but you want to start
using ansible and creating sandboxes on
demand how you might do that with
VirtualBox and vagrant
it also shows kind of if you're really
interested in seeing just the task
structure of ansible and how I have have
done the data data lab sandbox inside
ansible task structure that's available
to look through here so so finally I
want to kind of end on thinking about
like why did my talk get put in the
interoperability section just kind of
seems like an odd fit but I also really
like that it's in this section as well
because going back to the idea it's how
we get our legitimised in an
organization I often hear the stock
answer like show the value of our like
build a bunch of cool shiny apps and I
love shiny I do I'm writing a book about
shiny and protection apparently but but
but it isn't actionable if you don't
have like awesome killer shiny app ideas
so my my idea for you a better way to
frame this this sort of advice is to
think about linking the tools that you
love are to the tools that you know
other people love in your organization
powerful sandboxes really leverage
interoperability and we've done a lot of
work at our studio to make cool
integrations that are turning into to
true interoperability opportunities for
ours throughout my career I have had
like a lot of success helping get our
legitimized by putting it in terms of
other people's favorite tools and so
I'll leave you with that thank you
[Music]